Time magazine's Person of the Year has  just been revealed and that person is  drumroll please who reddit uber Wow yes  the 16 year old environmental activist  from Sweden gained global recognition  this year VIN Berg delivered a powerful  and emotional speech at this year's UN  climate action summit for words prompted  an international movement to fight  climate change Times Entertainer of the  Year is Liz oh that's right why man til  they gotta be great the first right 100%  yeah the first time that time is doing  this whether they're having the Person  of the Year and then individual stand  outside like yeah yeah can we show the  time cover again because it covers very  cool time covers so great with miss  Greta look very nice guys the young  activists all over the world have  sparked movements just like right yeah  yeah really true  all right Vlad Thanks